a CBS News poll on impeachment just out
this morning shows Americans are still
split out of tomorrow's first public
hearings 43 percent in our survey think
President Trump should be impeached over
the Ukraine controversy 40 percent say
he should not in 17 percent say it's
just too soon to say 73% of those who
have an opinion say they've already made
up their minds Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with more on this story and
Nancy with 24 hours and Counting before
the hearings began how are the Democrats
and Republicans finalizing their
strategies well overnight CBS News
obtained this 18 page memo date Gale
that details the Republican strategy
going into these public hearings they
are going to argue that the evidence
just doesn't prove that the president
pressured Ukraine covered up misconduct
or obstructed justice they're going to
claim that the president was simply
interested in combating legitimate
corruption in Ukraine a concern that
stemmed from his quote deep-seated
genuine and reasonable skepticism about
that country however according to the
testimony of two diplomatic aides that
was released on Monday the president
actually bought into some conspiracy
theories about Ukraine even insisting at
one meeting that quote Ukraine tried to
do him in one aid worried that if these
theories pushed by the president's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani took hold
that the Ukrainian government was an
enemy of the president then it would be
very hard to have high-level engagement
with Ukraine and Nancy we're also
learning new details about the military
aid to Ukraine that was approved by
Congress but then held up what do we
know that's right one of those
diplomatic aides Catherine Croft
testified that it was actually acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney at the
White House
at the direction of the president who
placed an informal hold on that military
aid this summer right before the
president's July phone call with the
president of Ukraine where he said he'd
like the president of Ukraine to do him
a favor also in the first testimony from
a Pentagon official Laura Cooper she's
the Deputy Assistant Secretary of State
testified that even
pentagons was in the dark this summer
about why the aid was being held up she
said that her understanding was that the
Ukrainians were aware that the aid was
being withheld and that's important
because it runs counter to the GOP
argument that there was no pressure here
because the Ukrainians didn't even know
that this aid had been withheld
Democrats argue that this is more
evidence that there was a quid pro quo
dirt on the Biden family in exchange for
the resumption of millions in military
aid and of course much more on all this
tomorrow Nancy thank you very much
CBS News will bring you complete
coverage of the first public hearings in
the impeachment inquiry Norah O'Donnell
will anchor special reports from
Washington tomorrow and Friday here on
CBS you can also find continuous
coverage on our streaming network cbsn